[Music]
first of all this is a journal not a
diary tomorrow is the first day of
middle school luckily i'm not alone in
this middle school thing i've got my
best friend riley
here's what you need to know watch where
you sit on the first day of school don't
use the bathroom on the second floor and
finally don't
get the cheese touch
because if you do you might as well be
dead
thank you roderick for that wonderful
pep talk
we're out of our league here
maybe my mom can homeschool me
hey greg want to come over here
play play play
[Music]
yep i'm pretty sure i'm gonna be in
therapy over this
we're in middle school now don't you
think it's time to start acting our age
frankly wanna see my
secret freckle i'm like permanently
scarred from that night
look at these little nerds i'll pass
their bedtime
[Music]
disgusting
[Music]
but for now stuck in middle school
surrounded by morons
if you just stick with me everything
will be fine
[Music]
oh sorry
i i thought you were teenagers are you
all right
you're all right
[Music]
foreign